socks are going to play baseball tonight
a little bit late
first pitch just a couple of moments
away after the rain delay but drying up
right now at fenway to play game two red
sox winning game one
impressively behind eduardo rodriguez
he is back in full force richards making
his fourth start
and seeking that first red sox victory
he's gone five the last two starts a
pair no decisions
richards comes in on a bichette with a
fastball
bow is not pleased given a little extra
look out to the mound
as he got hit on the left arm but the
command very
erratic in the early going for garrett
richards as buchet now walks down to
first
and a lot of that has to do with the way
he throws across his body
bo looking for that slider away and he
is clipped on
the arm not sure if it's his left arm or
his right arm derrick richards just
trying to find command of that fastball
he's not
on time look at how he throws that
across that binding he can't get that
upper half through his motion and
that'll make guerrero think as he steps
into the box richards has been
all over the place already with a walk
and a hit batter blue jay's looking to
strike early
and the first pitch to guerrero is
swinging a liner into left field for a
base hit
rounding third on his way home is biggio
he will score standing up buchet stops
at second
it's an rbi single for vladi in an early
one to nothing blue jay lead
and vladi has been on base every game
that's the right man in the right spot
that you want up there
sixth game of the season for trent
thornton as he gets his first start
in fact it's his first start since
august the 23rd of last season
he strokes that one into right field for
a base set
yeah he throw that fastball in his eyes
and he was kind of in a pull mode from
the get-go this is bad
to what he did two years ago in his best
year pulls it here
but he finds a hole between third and
short a liner into left field for a base
hit
2-2 in the air to right field
verdugo sets up to make the catch simeon
tags
on his way home and the throw is offline
and a third on the play as well comes
palacios
the blue jays lead two to nothing
palacios at third jansen at first
and the 2-2 a ground ball pulled to the
right side a sliding stop
by the second baseman of gonzalez
they'll get biggio but palacios in the
score janssen up to second
and it is three to nothing so with a
runner with second two down it'll be
beau buchet who was hit on the left arm
by a fastball from richards in the first
down
a big swing and a ground ball base hit
into right center field for
beshet and jensen will come in to score
to make it four to nothing blue jays
he's got a hit of spots to get out and
he's done that so far this year
2-2 and a swing and a miss on a breaking
ball in the dirt one down
one two and he got him great change up
down and away
strikes out another one two down runner
goes and the 3-2
swing and a miss malone gets him what a
job in the bottom of the third by
tommy malone still four nothing blue
jays
3-1 change back-to-back fastballs in
[Music]
gonna rip that one back toward the wall
skips onto the warning track
and he's going to head into second base
with an easy double so the red sox have
the lead off man aboard in the fourth
inning
and that'll be scooped up by buchet as a
run comes in to score
red sox on the board the rbi goes to
devers that'll be number 16 for rafael
it's a 4-1 games
did get a run lasting against malone
gonzalez will drive that to center field
grichik
can't get it gets past him and winds up
against the wall
and gonzalez is into second base so for
the second inning in a row the red sox
begin
with a double he tops the ground ball to
deep third
here's the throw by biscio on the move
drop everybody safe
the runner arrived as the ball was
bouncing and guerrero
didn't come up with it that did not look
like a hard throw to pick lou
no two and two
there's a shot that's a fair ball off
the short fence
gonzalez into score runners at second
and third and the red sox pull it in two
on a double by [ __ ] hernandez you cannot
sneak that fastball by him this ball is
up and in and he just
whistles this ball down the third
baseline the red sox have the bases
loaded with two down
bottom five four two j's goguards
digs in phelps gets his side first pitch
on the way
and he's swinging a ground ball to short
bushette has it throw to
first to get him and phelps gets out of
it
as the red sox leave the bases loaded
2-2 back to the mound it hits bryce
bounces over towards third and gritchik
will reach on an infield hit
that's a good start let's see if they
can bring him around
1-2 hit hard and pass the diving devers
bounces off the short wall into shallow
left
and the throw into third that'll be a
single
for simeon grichik rounded second then
retreated to the bag two on with nobody
out for the jays
xander now fly to left grounded up 4-3
with the bases loaded in the fifth it
went after the first pitch
he golf that one high deep drive hit it
for left
and that one gets out of here home run
it just had enough zander for the
second night in a row and that tightens
it up it's a one-run game
boy he did some work on that ball down
that ball is down on the ground
how he does this is beyond me it's just
he didn't that far
kept it fair i don't know gotta help
them there a little tapper
low throw and it gets thrown
through that one away vasquez rumbling
on down to third
and gonzalez into second red sox catch a
break
the inning should be over and the pitch
a swing and a ground ball to third
longer throw for biggio and he gets
it to guerrero they get dull back
the inning is over the red sox leave a
couple of men on
boba shed one for three with an rbi
single in the second a swing and a
swinging bunt up the third baseline bear
handed it by taylor and he doesn't have
a play but shed aboard with an infield
hit
the 1-0 and there's a line driving to
right field
but shed around third as the ball kicks
away
and beau will come into score standing
up
guerrero around third as verdugo had
trouble with it
and there's the line drive that he's
been waiting for the blue jays
now lead five to three runners on the
corners one out for randall grichik and
he lines one to right center
and that's down for a base hit guerrero
will come in to score
kirk around to third on a long single by
grichik and it is 6-3
and the 0-1 on the way slider again and
a swing of the ground ball to third
biggio has it across to guerrero in time
and the blue jays will win it it took a
while
and it was a grind but they snapped
their three-game losing streak
with a 6-3 win at fenway park